I want to begin this video by reviewing
the definition of complements so the
definition of a complement of a set for
the for instance the complement of a
equals the set containing elements X
such that X is not an element of a I
will now be going over two new algebraic
laws for sets the first are the law of
complements the law of complements
states that if we take the union of a
set and its complement it equals a
universe or if you take the complement
of the null set it equals the universe
furthermore the intersection of a set
and its complement is the null set and
that should be clear because if you have
the set a and you are intersecting it
with everything that is not inside a
there's a clearly not going to be any
overlap so you're gonna have an empty
set the next one is the law of
involution so involution states that if
we have a state here
let's cut we'll call it state zero and
we feed that state to a function in this
case we're gonna feed it to the
complement function then when it gets to
state one if we again feed it through
the exact same function the complement
function it will result in state zero
again in this case if we fed state if we
fed set a through this cyclical function
here then we would have a feed it
through a complement we get a complement
feed it back through the function we get
a complement complement which equals a
and then we could have a complement
couple of a complement which would be a
complement and then you get the idea
it's cyclical